welcome to new game 15 minute game here
and Isis seem I lost a couple of seconds
because I got a bit confused with the
dogma growth broadcast here so I had
some dog man moves mixed in here and
that was quite weird but now I'm I'm
started and opens the silly in here and
I'm playing on he had the classical
variation here so not the one known you
sloth attack with f3 and long castles
and so on but this some this old line
here it is an old favorite girl from
anatoly karpov played it dumb you hand
the late 70s and early 80's and it's
certainly not a bad line for white main
advantage shown compared to this long
cancelling lines of course that you can
actually am yeah try to find moves
yourself and don't need to memorize all
those long sharp lines aha i thought i
would i would have prevented this move
because of bishop f6 and takes on d5 but
he obviously thinks he can play it
anyway so let's say Bishop f6 Bishop f6
ed5 Bishop c3m this must be s IDM be
take C then you can capture on d5 yeah
okay maybe this is possible so let's
check quickly he takes d5 just eat takes
d5 yeah you can just take with a night
alright so Bishop have six Bishop of 695
you just once once the capture be too
yeah this is most likely okay for black
so amazing he can play the smooth
what else I mean night c5 maybe but i'm
not sure if you maybe can play deform
and chase mice III night away I don't
want to move this piece
interesting so did I really yeah maybe
added term which I have to move all day
here somehow okay so not much choice um
if I cannot find anything else I need to
take here and trying to play this
position which arises after Bishop f6
ed5 bishops III bc 3 and he takes on d5
I have some ideas in this position
that's not entirely pointless I'm own
somewhat better developed so um maybe
there's something in this okay but I
could I could think of I'm now I thought
maybe taking all these six but he really
can take the rook engine has got no
problems okay need to capture him
question is how does he take now if he
takes what the Queen I would have played
Bishop f3 okay and in this position
night c5 he might just play these 60 b6
yeah be 64 takes on g2 where the weird
position hmm not sure I want to want to
allow that I could play c4b should be
695 this is a bit irritating for black
maybe he needs to even go back to c 8
okay I must try that I think the still
looks look Sam like white maybe can make
something office development advantage
from structural point of view of course
these pawns are ugly haha
hmm ok I have potentially discoveries
with the bishop on we caught this Bishop
is just loose but nothing nothing great
available I guess ok so just 95 checking
efore and b7 so I should should get the
b7 porn and interesting question is what
happens if you take ste one should I
capture with the bishop really winning a
pawn captioned with the bishop boom
protects it too but I could also take
with the rook which looks som they are
much more logical really more dynamic so
quindi one route 81 maybe mm or ed one
who always difficult at some moment
maybe rupee one might be good so hard to
tell which Joker is better but I think
just quindi one Rock 81 who looks good
Bishop see to rock d to Bishop f5 yeah
and then should I just take b7r or is it
an idea to to play Bishop f3 first
activating the bishop and I think I
should just take
maybe that I I have a slight advantage
with the sea pawn and some nothing
nothing rate though not quite sure what
what he's thinking about okay maybe but
yeah okay though I maybe I get it now
Bishop f5 97 maybe he's looking for
Queen moves queen be sick so I can
answer with rook be one yeah but this is
a valid idea it could could think of
Bishop f5 here yeah it related I would
take d8 now yeah it doesn't make much
sense to him give him the default really
and not be seven
there are 97 Quincy seven I need to
return to see five then it's got rope
the eight okay okay this may be what sir
was pretty pretty good idea to play
Bishop f5 here immediately are there any
other ideas they're taking on b7 a
bishop f3 can just play Quincy 7i guess
and it's just nothing
hmm I move like G for kicking the bishop
p.m. I think I just play who queen bee
sixth i found some Queen move couldn't
be six
then I could I put play 9 p-3 back LG LG
for us are really already with move um
just weakening I guess but 9p 727s also
not great don't like this so much but ok
what can you do Quincy 7 and just 95 and
then it's got rope the aid I also need
to be a careful about 90 for covering up
or night before this kind of moves the
up like and certainly ok here yeah good
defensive push up at five maybe 95 but
95 must have been right I guess
difficult so now Rock ft ATM and then
the question is what what should I play
some some interposing move like Bishop
d3 or 93 I'll move the Queen if i move
the Queen I have to reckon with this
night move Knight d4 night before
yeah like it sir ok anyway whatever I do
bishop I don't like Quincy one really
you can play at least stuff like night
before an ID for 94 93 takes on e 2
takes our d3n turn black as a fine game
so but if I take place something on
these three MIT play a 5v5 okay i need
to to do something if he goes if I've
now I was thinking about Quincy one
covering the f4 square so that furthered
wants us all along either form you can
still play a night before I move like
this alright so twin here so that on e4
I can play Knight f form if he goes
Knight d4 I will play Bishop f1 I guess
yeah it should have one oh wait wait
wait wait not so quick maybe maybe not
before but not before I can take both
check and play Quincy for ok but I have
this idea now like before as a threat i
think or LED an idea at least not before
to d5 and his pawn on e5 is hanging now
so he needs to react somehow ok so this
shouldn't be too bad really neither for
neither 45
this is the difference before deformer
he could he could move III mp3 ever f95
I mean 95 is just really strong so this
should be it should be okay
we're not either if he plays III now I
can yeah what should I play I mean
there's more than one move I could also
just take it even with the rook has III
rookie three Queen f4 okie 8 as possible
Queenie 392 also also possible i have
this 995 is just really strong it would
cost an exchange i think with all this
Knight f6 ideas since should really be
fine now for me would be surprised a
firm he's got some some great idea now
if he a mini card cover d 5 which is the
issue there should be six them I could
simply take it only form of better even
now place III Knight Returns and then um
then grab your form or take it 6 square
before which is just a nice em extra
phone
yeah that sure don't see a good move
really maybe he can he must think of
along the lines of allowing 95 okay nope
lady three so what now I like this
rookie three I mean okay let's let's do
this systematically if I take with the
pony place Queen Anne I'd see to right
and this is not so so great with this
somewhat rag pawn structure but what
about rook III you cannot take on f4
because of this check here if you take
see to apply 95 and not sure if you can
really move the Queen oh yeah maybe you
can if you would sec on d5 I check with
the porn and he cannot move the bishop
is in a pincer
another idea just thought about what
states taking with the pawn Knight takes
84 but it looks looks a bit shaky all
right so I don't I spend too much time
here so 90 59 with really am this
renewal eyes them upon the fact that
this is just a super strong piece but ok
I just others them recognize he cannot
really move the Queen as I also have 97
f 5 which would just win I mean if he
plays something like Queen Queen a five
year i think i can i can really just
play 97 and if he takes on d5 which
would yeah which looks normal really to
get rid of the night i would recapture
and then it cannot take either one of my
looks because it's a see file pin we're
going on c1 pins the the Queen and okay
can move the Queen and try to get back
the exchanger next move but I have a
move then and the question is if I have
a good one probably i have but at least
it would leave me with an extra porn the
extra deep on
yeah I cannot really believe he M can
move the Queen now Queen a 50 k our
queen 85 isn't playable at all i guess i
can play rookie five then also rookie
five with discovered ideas 97 96 winning
the queen so it cannot take the rook and
I threaten all kinds of stuff even rook
takes f5 and he needs to take the five
dr. not much choice
yeah ok so here I've got ya I need to
need to check this carefully now the
possibility as I can take on III arts
also G for what my father said the
energy for distracting this Bishop here
but you can take III and then G form so
G for some just a nonsense move Bishop
c4 would look AO looks a decent at first
but he can play rook c8 this is so
somewhat somewhat tough to to counter ok
when I really need two to keep this poem
it should be two to f3 something like
this
now we're really not easy here to UM to
keep something here
we should be too we might even like we
never 6 cm which might be really
embarrassing move to phase queen have 60
70 thread now
what a weird position you really am
defended this quite well I guess okay so
what else is there any any rook moves I
mean he can t just takes this is the
issue he just takes on now on d5 cannot
plain played in a way that at the end I
i can even I can somehow get some play
against them against f7 yeah this which
would be at least something okay let's
um let's try this move here he takes a
one Queen takes 25 I can play Bishop c4
and then try to do something against f7
but of course some time is some is an
issue here
if you would play a queen d for now I
can can take f7 king at seven Roxy seven
winning the Queen and I think really I
can take now or is it some some trick to
put me in a in a nasty pin here we
should have seven king cakes we should
be three Lucas II aid I can play rook
see one right so okay so it just took
this instantly why so what they're
thinking I'm just blundering this thing
or what so right so I have got the Queen
now against rukan Bishop but two and a
half minutes down first making some room
for the King here if we place the rook
now I can play quindi for double
attacking a seven and d7
roop c7 hmm works in seven maybe teenage
through and 26 isolated is let us check
here okay but this doesn't really help
yeah so Roxy 726 is fine the Chekhov
King age 12 of threatening Queen f4
check so this doesn't really matter yeah
now this hangs and queen f4 maybe I'm
winning more material instantly which
would help a lot with this time and I
don't really see move this is hanging
okay this may be the only move but I can
play g4g for it's good right you have to
form so that I can actually check on f4
picking up the rook yeah okay this must
be winning now winning a piece yeah
black had really am bad coordination
here can just take right yeah and also
taking this
continues so anyway to to end this
clicker can it's just get the a porn
rolling
time warning so what's relief that's
really there should be some way to pick
up the rookie up King h5 Queen f7 picks
up broke joke black resigns yeah now we
resigned yea rather interesting game I
was he defended very very well I think
for quite some time this position on the
special point five was a good move and
here black must be perfectly okay the
rookie move should be I should be fine
then I played they played this year yeah
the computer actually now gives 90
forward though some advantage to Blackie
I can believe this I mean black is very
active d5 Quincy one yeah he still gives
black a good position 94 also very
logical but now if I really am three if
I was was a bad move here he really
needs to go on with a normal move here
something like him yeah f6 if you want
to play it safe but Brooke ba Jiao to
compute a suggestion he is quite nice it
done it covers the square here canvas do
the before square and the service helps
so that I cannot play night before and
II form it just has the problem that it
allows my 92 to d5 I hit the compounds
to take on c2 we are what was the
quality okay and not sure if this
yeah the computer actually wants to play
Bishop c4 here I was really a bit
annoyed about rook c8 maybe this wasn't
so much of a problem but it looked
problematic to me so this oh yeah and
now he just done needs to play Queen e5
and it's just dead until this just
blunders upon short but I don't know it
took 2 seconds to to grab this and I
don't understand really it's got four
minutes on the clock and I mean you can
look at the writing that I'm not to
complete penser so okay so so I want the
chain here and here I think he instantly
lose even more material like it so badly
coordinated yeah alright think an
interesting game he really spoiled it
with the c-4 move I always need to take
into account with what kind of squares
you you give the opponent if you move
pawn cialis the old famous saying they
cannot move backwards is really a really
true and they just gave me this the
slide rule this nice route here with the
with a night here the zone 35 square
alright thanks for watching you and talk
to you soon with the new video is also
in English the dogmen tournament is so
close to finish now and after that i'll
switch back to to the usual english
comentary